in the last video we started to talk
about how to parameterize
a torus or a donut shape and the two
parameters we're using and i spent a lot
of time trying to visualize it because
this is all about visualization i think
this is really the hard thing to do here
but the way we can parameterize the
surface of or taurus which is the
surface of this donut is say hey let's
take a point
and let's take let's rotate it around a
circle it could be any circle i picked a
circle in the z y plane and how far it's
gone around that circle we'll
parameterize that by s and s can go
between zero all the way to two pi and
then we're going to rotate this circle
around itself or we i guess even better
way to say we're going to rotate the
circle around the z axis and it's all
the center of the circles are always
going to keep a distance b away and so
these were top views right there and
then we defined our second parameter t
which tells us how far the entire circle
has rotated around the z axis and those
were our those are our two parameter
definitions and then here we try to
visualize what happens this is kind of
the domain that our parameterization is
going to be defined on s goes between 0
and 2 pi so when t is 0 we haven't
rotated out of the z y plane
s is at 0 goes all the way to 2 pi over
there then when t goes to 2 pi we've
kind of moved
moved our circle we've moved it along
we've rotated around the z-axis a bit
and then this line in our st domain
corresponds to that circle in three
dimensions or in our x y z
space
now given that hopefully we visualize it
pretty well let's think about actually
how to define a position vector valued
function
that will
that is essentially this
parameterization
so let's first do the z because that's
pretty straightforward
so let's look at this view right here
what's our z going to be as a function
so our x our y's and our z's should all
be a function of s and t that's what
it's all about we want to our any
position in space should be a function
of picking a particular t and a
particular s and we saw that over here
this point right here let me actually do
that with a couple of points
this point right there that corresponds
to that point right there
let me pick another one this point
right here corresponds to this point
right over there i could do a few more
let me pick this point right here so s
is still 0 that's going to be this outer
edge way out
over there i'll pick one more just to
define this square
this point right over here where we
haven't rotated t at all but we've gone
halfway or
we've gone a quarter way around the
circle it's that point right there so
for any s and t we're mapping it to a
point in x y z space so our z's our x's
and our y's should all be a function of
s and t
so the first one to think about is just
the z
i think this will be pretty
straightforward
so z
as a function of s
and t
is going to equal what
well if you take any circle remember s
is how much we're going
how much the angle between our radius
and the x y plane so i could even draw
it over here let me do it in
another color
so i'm running out of colors so let's
say that this is a radius right there
that angle we said that is s so if i
were to draw that circle out
if i were to draw that circle out just
like that we can do a little bit of
trigonometry
this is the angle is s
we know the radius is a
the radius of our circle we define that
so the z is just going to be the
distance above
or the distance above the x y plane it's
going to be this distance right there
and that's straightforward trigonometry
that's going to be a i mean we could do
sohcahtoa and all of that you might want
to review the videos
but the sign
you could view it this way
so this is if this is z right there you
could say that the sine
of s
sohcahtoa is the opposite over the
hypotenuse is equal to z
over a multiply both sides by a you have
a sine
of s is equal to z that tells us how
much above the x y plane we are and that
you know just some simple trigonometry
so z of s and t it's only going to be a
function of s it's going to be a
a
times the sine of s
not too bad now let's see if we can
figure out what x and y are going to be
remember z doesn't matter it doesn't
matter how much we've rotated around
around the z axis what matters is how
much we've rotated around the circle if
s is 0 we're just going to be in the x y
plane z is going to be 0 if x is
oh sorry if s is pi over 2 or up here
then we're going to be traveling around
the top of the doughnut and we're going
to be exactly a above the x y plane or z
is going to be equal to a hopefully that
makes reasonable sense to you now let's
think about what happens
what happens as we rotate around
remember these two are top views we are
looking down
we're looking down on this doughnut so
the center of each of these circles is b
away
from the origin or from yeah from the
origin or from the z axis what we're
rotating around it's always b away so
our x coordinate or our x and y
coordinates so if we go to the center of
the circle here we're going to be b away
and then this is going to be
b away
right over there so let's think about
kind of where we are in the x y plane or
how far
the the part of our when we're i guess
you could imagine the if you were to
project our point into the x y plane how
far is that going to be from our origin
well it's always going to be remember
let's go back to this drawing here this
might be the most instructive
i'm not this is just one particular
circle on the z y plane but it could be
any of them if this is the z axis over
here
that is the z axis
this distance right here is always going
to be b we know that for sure
and so what is this distance going to be
what is the distance
what is
this distance going to be where b to the
center and then we're going to have some
angle s and so depending on that angle s
this distance onto i guess the x y plane
you know for sitting on the x y plane
how far are we from the z axis or the
projection onto the x y plane or you can
you know the the x or the y position i'm
saying it as many ways as possible i
think you're visualizing it if z is a
sine of theta this distance right here
this little shorter distance right here
that's going to be a cosine of theta
a cosine not of theta of s
right s is that angle right there this
distance right here is going to be a
cosine of s so if we talk about just
straight distance
from the origin along the x y plane our
distance is always going to be
it's always going to be b
plus
a
cosine of s when a gets you know when s
is out here then it's actually going to
become a negative number and that makes
sense because our distance is going to
be less than b we're going to be at that
point right there so if you look at
these top views
if you look at the top views over here
no matter where we are you know that is
b and let's say we've rotated a little
bit that distance right here if you look
along the x
y plane that is always going to be
b plus a cosine of
s that's what that distance is
to any given point we're depending on
our s's and t's
now as we rotate around
if this if we're at a point here
let's say we're at a point there and
that point
we already said is b plus a cosine
of s
away from the origin on the x y plane
what are the x and y coordinates of that
well remember this is a top down we're
looking we're sitting on the z axis
looking straight down on the x y plane
right now we're looking down on the
doughnut
so what is what are your x and y's going
to be well you draw another right
triangle right here you have another
right triangle this angle right here is
t
this distance right here is going to be
this times the sine of our angle so
this
right here which is essentially our x
this is going to be our x coordinate
x
as a function of s
and t
is going to be equal to
the sine of t
the sine of t t is our angle right there
times this radius times well we could
write either way times b plus
a cosine
of s because remember how far we are
depends on how much around the circle we
are right when we're over here we're
much further away here we're exactly b
away if you're looking only on the x y
plane and then over here where b minus a
away if we're looking if we're on the x
y plane so that's x as a function of s
and t and actually the way i defined it
right here
and it you know it this would our
positive x-axis would actually go in
this direction
so this is
x positive this is x in the negative
direction i could have flipped the signs
but hopefully you know this actually
makes sense that that would be the
positive x this is the negative x it
depends on whether using a right-handed
or left-handed coordinate system but
hopefully that makes sense we're just
saying okay what is this distance right
here that is b plus a cosine of s
we got that from
this right here when we're taking a view
just kind of a
a cut of the torus
that's how far we are in kind of the x y
direction at any point
or kind of radially out without thinking
about the height and then if you want
the x coordinate you multiply it times
the cosine or sorry you multiply times
the sine of t the way i've set it up
here and the y coordinate
the y coordinate is going to be this
right here the way we've set up this
triangle so y as a function of s and t
is going to be equal to the cosine of t
cosine of t
times
this radius
b plus a
cosine
of s
and so our parameterization and you know
just play with this triangle and
hopefully it'll make sense i mean if you
say that this is our y coordinate right
here you just do sohcahtoa cosine of t
is equal to adjacent which is y right
this is the angle right here over the
hypotenuse over b plus a
cosine of
s multiply both sides of the equation
times this you get y
you get y of s of t is equal to cosine
of t times this thing right there
so let me copy and paste all of our
takeaways
let me
copy it
and then paste it and we're done with
our parameterization
we're done with our parameterization we
could leave it just like this but if we
want to define it as a if we want to
represent it as a position vector valued
function we can define it like this
find a nice color
and maybe pink
so let's say our position vector
function vector valued function is r is
going to be a function of two parameters
s
and
t
and it's going to be equal to its x
value
let me do that in the same color so it's
going to be i'll do this part first b
plus a cosine
of s
times
sine
of t and that's going to go in the x
direction so we'll say that's times
i and in this case remember the way i
defined it the positive x direction is
going to be here so the i unit vector
will look like that
i will look like we'll go in that
direction the way i've defined things
and then
plus
our y value is going to be
b plus a cosine
of
s
times
cosine
of t
in the
y unit vector direction remember the j
unit vector will just go just like that
that's our j unit vector and then
finally we'll throw in the z which was
actually the most straightforward
plus
a
sine of s
times the k unit vector which is the
unit vector in the z direction
so times the k unit vector and so you
give me
now any s and t within this domain right
here any s t within this domain right
here and you give it put it into
this
position vector valued function it'll
give you the exact position vector that
specifies the appropriate point on the
torus
so if you pick
let's just make sure we understand what
we're doing
if you pick that point right there where
s and t are both equal to pi over 2 and
you might even want to go through the
exercise take pi over 2 in all of these
actually let's let's let's do it so in
that case so when r
of pi over 2
pi over 2 what do we get it's going to
be b plus a times cosine of pi over 2.
cosine of pi over 2 is 0 right cosine of
90 degrees so it's going to be b
right this whole thing is going to be 0
times sine of pi over 2. sine of pi over
2 is just 1. so it's going to be b times
i
plus
once again cosine of pi over 2
is 0 so this term right here is going to
be b
and then cosine of pi over 2 is 0. so
it's going to be 0 j
so it's going to be plus 0 j
and then finally pi over 2 well you have
a t there's no t here sine of pi over 2
is 1. so plus a times k
plus
a times k so there's actually no j
direction so this is going to be equal
to b times i
plus
a times k
so the point that it specifies according
to this parameterization or the vector
espresso is b times i plus a times k
so b times i
b times i will get us right out there
and then a
times k will get us right over there so
the position vector being specified is
right over there
just as we predicted that dot that point
right there corresponds to that point
just like that and of course i picked
kind of points it was easy to calculate
but this whole
when you take every s and t in this
domain right here you're going to
transform it to this surface and this is
the transformation right here and of
course we have to specify that
s is between
we could write it multiple ways we could
well would just write s is between 2 pi
s is between 2 pi and 0 and we could
also say t is
between 2 pi and 0 and you could you
know we're kind of overlapping one extra
time at 2 pi so maybe we can get rid of
one of these equal signs if you like
although that won't necessarily that
won't change the area any if you're
taking the surface area but hopefully
this gives you at least a gut sense or
more than a gut sense of how to
parameterize these things and what we're
even doing because it's going to be
really important when we start talking
about surface integrals and the hardest
thing about doing all of this is just
the visualization